good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the
utter fraudulence of tony fauci is
obvious now and it's widely acknowledged
but it was not always obvious
in march of last year we interviewed
fauci on this show we treated him with
respect we took his answers seriously
we're americans so we assumed the man in
charge of protecting the u.s from covid
must be
rational and impressive we also assumed
he must be honest
but we were wrong it soon became clear
that tony fauci was just another
sleazy federal bureaucrat deeply
political and often dishonest
more shocking than that we then learned
that fauci himself was
implicated in the very pandemic he'd
been charged with fighting
fauci supported the grotesque and
dangerous experiments
that appeared to have made kovid
possible
we came to these conclusions
incrementally spurred by evidence that
accumulated over the course of a year
tonight we have the mother lode thanks
to a freedom of information request from
buzzfeed
we have thousands of emails to and from
anthony fauci they go back to the early
winter of 2020.
collectively they show that from the
beginning tony fauci was
worried that the public might conclude
covid had originated at the wuhan
institute of virology now why would tony
fauci be concerned that americans would
conclude that
possibly because tony fauci knew
perfectly well that he had
funded gain of function experiments at
that very same laboratory
the emails proved that fauci lied about
this under oath
consider this exchange which began the
evening of january 31st 2020
it was a friday just before midnight the
first email came from an immunologist
called christian anderson who works at
the scripps research institute in la
jolla california
anderson warned fauci that kovitt
appeared to have been
possibly manipulated in a laboratory
quote the unusual
features of the virus make up a really
small part of the genome less than 0.1
percent
so one has to look really closely at all
the sequences to see that some of the
features potentially
look engineered the next day on february
1st tony fauci wrote back
thanks christian talk soon on the call
fauci then sent an
urgent email to his deputy a man called
hugh auchenklaus
the subject of that email in all caps
was important
quote hugh it is essential that we speak
this am
keep your cell phone on read this paper
as well as the email that i will forward
you will have tasks today that must be
done
attached to that email was a document it
was entitled quote
barrick she at all nature medicine
sars gain of function dot pdf
now the bark in the attachment referred
to ralph barr
a virologist based in the u.s who
collaborated with the wuhan institute of
virology
barak worked with a woman called dr xi
sheng li known as the
bat lady because she manipulates
chronoviruses that infect bats
she was the she in the attachment now
keep in mind that during the questioning
from senator rand paul of kentucky
fairly recently tony fauci denied that
this same ralph barack had conducted
gain of function research again
this is the ralph barik in fouchi's
attachment which was entitled barack
she at all sars gain of function dot pdf
and yet under oath before the united
states congress
fauci denied this dr barrett does not
doing gain to function research and if
it is
it's according to the guidelines and it
is being conducted in north
carolina and if you look at the grant
and you look at the
progress reports it is not gain a
function
despite the fact that people tweet that
oh it wasn't just on twitter it was in
fauci's own emails
in retrospect that looks a lot like
perjury
we do know that starting early last year
a lot of people at nih were worried that
covid had not
occurred naturally they were concerned
it had been instead manipulated in a lab
in china
and yet they seemed determined to hide
those facts from the public
again why on the afternoon of february
1st last year fauci held a conference
call with several top virologists
most of the details of that call were
made hidden from public view they've
been redacted
we know the call was related to a
document entitled coronavirus sequence
comparison
jeremy farrar a british physician who
runs a major research nonprofit
reminded everyone on the call that what
they said was top secret
quote information and discussion is
shared in total confidence and not to be
shared until agreement on next steps end
quote
in other emails jamie farrar passed
along an article from the website zero
hedge
that piece suggested the chronovirus
might have been created as a bio weapon
we now know that is a more plausible
explanation than the one we believed
at first and were told by the media
which is that corona came from a
pangolin and yet for the crime of saying
that out loud a more plausible
explanation zero hedge was banned from
social media platforms
until recently you were not allowed to
suggest that kovid might be man-made
why couldn't you suggest that the fact
checkers wouldn't allow it
why wouldn't they because tony fauci
assured the tech monopolies
that the chronovirus could not have been
man-made and so the tech monopolies
shut down the topic watch fauci lie
a group of highly qualified
evolutionary virologists look at the
sequences there and the sequences
in bats
as they evolve and the mutations that it
took
to get to the point where it is now is
totally consistent with a jump of a
species from an animal to a human
that was april 17 2020 very
shortly into the course of this pandemic
at that point what tony fauci just
asserted as
known could not conclusively have been
known
that was a lie tony fauci suggested that
he knew because
top researchers had decided conclusively
that this must have jumped naturally
from an animal to a human being but
again at that point
he could not have known that that was
dishonest
two days after he said that one of the
virologists that tony fauci had
funded to conduct dangerous chronovirus
experiments in wuhan
wrote to thank him for the help that man
a man called peter dazyk
complained to fauci that the american
tax dollars he'd taken for these
experiments
were being quote publicly targeted by
fox news reporters
yet dasic remained grateful for tony
fauci's support
quote i just wanted to say a personal
thank you on behalf of our staff
and collaborators end quote now
strangely
most of this specific email from dasic
to fauci
has been redacted and it was redacted
under foia section b7a
that specific exemption to the foia law
applies to quote
records or information compiled for law
enforcement purposes but only to the
extent that production of those
documents
could reasonably be expected to
interfere with enforcement proceedings
are peter dasik and tony fauci under a
criminal investigation we can only hope
they are
they certainly deserve it at this point
we can't say for sure
we do know that fauci hasn't simply lied
about the origins
of kovid pretending to know things he
could not know he has also lied about
vaccines
in key ways in march of last year former
obama official zeke emanuel wrote to
fouchy to ask a very simple question one
that we've asked countless times
are people who have recovered from covid
generally
immune from getting infected with covid
once again
that applies to about 100 million
americans so it's not a small question
fauci's response quote no evidence in
this regard but you would assume that
there would be substantial
immunity post infection well yes you
would assume that we always have
and in fact studies now show it is true
people who have had coveted and
recovered almost never get sick again
from covet
so they don't need to be vaccinated yet
to this day
tony fauci has never admitted that in
public
in his email to zeke emmanuel he
admitted something else that's also
now obvious surgical masks the paper
kind
all of us wear don't really work they
offer very little protection from covet
in fact at least one study shows they
may accelerate transmission of viruses
they are in short a form of make believe
yet once again while under oath in
public tony fauci claimed
precisely the opposite you're telling
everybody to wear a mask whether they've
had an infection or a vaccine what i'm
saying is they have immunity and
everybody agrees they have immunity what
studies do you have
that people that have had the vaccine or
have had the infection
are spreading the infection if we're not
spreading the infection isn't it just
theater no it's not the vaccine and
you're wearing two masks isn't that
theater no that's not here we go again
with the theater
let me just state for the record that
masks are not
theater masks are protective and we
actually community there theater
if you already have immunity you're
wearing a mask to give comfort to others
you're not wearing a mask because of any
sign i totally disagree with you
rand paul is a physician he's smart what
he just said was true
and the science shows that it's true
there's not much debate about it
actually among honest people but tony
fauci claimed it wasn't true he lied
why would he do that well here's one
reason the emails show that tony fauci
speaks regularly to bill gates
that's odd bill gates is not a doctor
bill gates is not a scientist bill gates
is a very rich man
who made billions making mediocre
software for office computers
so why would tony fauci be in such
regular contact with bill gates
the term bill gates comes up more than
two dozen times when you search the
fouchy emails
has bill gates profited in any way from
tony fauci's covid guidance
that would definitely be worth knowing
immediately
and yet we don't know our media don't
seem interested in finding out
in fact here's how cnn covered the
emails today quote
thousands of emails from and to dr fauci
revealed the weight that came with his
role
as a rare source of frank honesty within
the trump administration's covet 19
task force can you imagine a more
dishonest characterization
of anything than that it's hard to
by the way it wasn't just cnn no
reporters asked about these emails at
today's white house press briefing not
one question
but you shouldn't be surprised of course
they didn't ask tony fauci is too big
to question at this point quote oh my
god
one biden voter wrote to tony fauci back
in march
is there anything i can do for you
besides being grateful
wash my feet with your tears fauci may
have responded we can't say that he did
respond that way for certain we don't
have his reply
we do know that an affluent
neighborhoods throughout northwest
washington dc you can still see signs
that say
thank you dr fauci what does that tell
you
it tells you that tony fauci is no
longer a scientist assuming he ever was
one
tony fauci is a figure of religious
veneration
he is jesus for people who don't believe
in god
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else